les frites fraîches et un mais j'avais
pas vu j'avais pas vu non pas celle ci
celle qui vient de passer en attaque ça
on importe comment et en a rien à [ __ ]
de travail ou de battement région du
west
[Musique]
c'est pas des cigarettes cigares et
lettres françaises non vous êtes une
seule à mercy west
[Musique]
vous avez rien à faire
roland êtes hollandaise de la chance de
lui le match de foot
la famille jackson l'ajax l'ajax ah oui
ouais
deutsche bank est quelqu un acte
terrible un méchant ouais et moi et moi
[Rires]
et moi quel caractère je peux avoir pour
lui demandait pourquoi tu la regardes
est comme ça il est beau oulala je
comprends rien
vous en avez la grèce n'est pas encore
un peu à part à ma venue des drags et
deux jeunes filles c'est un échec
puisque vous retrouver tout seul un
échec on n'aurait pas dû presser de
transition fait un sourire
si ça marche continue ont commencé à
discuter sur n'importe quoi est ce que
ça t'arrive tu vois par exemple draguer
celle jeter des sourires mais ça
m'arrive mais tout seul mais pas
seulement en gros qu'on a on est plus en
confiance en groupe ou en groupe ça
marche pas quant à 2 ou 3 2 et quels
sont les endroits
mon travail c'est michel les arbres
matures où il ya de la verdure ou dans
un parc
mais ça marche au luxembourg ça va mieux
je ne vois aller vers les filles qui
sont difficiles encore je sais pas parce
que des filles faciles mon masque la
plupart du temps se fait avoir sur les
alpes à n'y a fait c'est nous qui payons
des 15-18 ans de west
[Musique]
on souhaite les pensez vous que les
jeunes que vous connaissez bien drague
de la même façon qu'on draguer par
exemple il ya dix quinze ans je crois
que si j'en juge par mon expérience je
crois qu'il d'actu lebrac lui parce que
il y avait un changement radical dans
les rapports entre les garçons et les
filles il y a dix ou quinze ans il y
avait deux milieux hétérogènes qui
cherchait évidemment à se rejoindre
alors la fille étaient coquettes et le
garçon était dragueur et il y avait une
espèce d'entente au niveau du jeu
maintenant la situation est telle que
étant donné la mixité des écoles des
lycées
il n'y a plus besoin de draguer et même
je crois dans les milieux où on ne va
pas tellement ou longtemps à l'école il
y a un rapport beaucoup plus direct
entre le garçon et la fille de telle
sorte que le dragage devient un peu
inutile ou alors vraiment s'il se
maintient c'est tout à fait au niveau du
jeu au niveau de l'affirmation de soi
[Musique]
e
je cherchais sable où vous faites en
région là on s'amusait avec le voit à
quoi celle des patins oui petit rémi
féraud mithois cendrillon ses deux
prénoms que je préfère quels principes
vous êtes là longtemps
rentré quand chez nous
j'habitais exactement
pourquoi
pas tout à fait 25 ans j'avais tout à
côté là mais on peut y aller
[Musique]
on venait donc vous êtes drôles de
timides ou alors puisqu'il m'afficher
deux filles pareil est ce que ça vous
arrive souvent de vous faire draguer
dans la rue ou dans le parc commis si
oui qu'en général je te fais draguer ou
toi est-ce que tu as un petit ami oui et
alors où tu dois rencontrer dans les
yvelines
comment une telle vague est ce que c'est
lui qui t'attend actuellement c'est moi
que toi oui qu'est ce que tu lui as dit
c'est les filles qui utilisaient des
transmissions
c'est pas moi directement comment tu as
pas les flics et des transmissions ça
c'étaient des amis et qui disait allez
faut danser avec quelque chose comme ça
tu avais des petites camarades qui
allait draguer pour tous alors si je
comprends bien il a marché
oui et toi est-ce que tu as un petit
camara la petite amie à comment ça s'est
passé
c'est au lycée aussi serré par
transmission le fait jamais n'arrive
jamais à faire le premier pas les filles
je crois n'acceptent plus d'être dragué
elles ont bien raison mais ce qu elle
drague elle-même les feux un bar oui
peut-être
peut-être allons-nous assister à un
phénomène inverse doit être la forme la
plus odieuse du dragage
c'est le 19e siècle c'est le duc
randolph essayant de lever la midinette
vient de lever la petite main c'est à
dire profitant de sa situation de
supériorité pour avoir une aventure
facile est ce que vous êtes venus ici
dans l'espoir de rencontrer quelqu'un
on devrait lui pas mais enfin que penser
quand je pense toujours qu'il est
possible sans remportera sentent au
hasard de
est ce qu'une terrasse de café comme ici
est un lieu de choix pour tondre habibou
se faire draguer parce que beaucoup de
passage
[Musique]
je drague tout ça parce que je n'y a pas
des connaissances je me fallait
connaissance puis
jeanne également
on drague c'est dans ce but l'un aussi
uniquement pour plaisir de faire une
rencontre à quelqu'un on leur a souvent
c'est surtout propice aux grands arbres
à cames ça se termine
comme ça des affinités
il le tir en rafale l'a déjà dragué par
quatre est ce que quelqu'un tour de
suivre un game comment réagissent les
filles que vous drague
joe drake pas dragon d'amendé j'ai connu
une petite ville brésilienne je prends
s'étaient tour au recto où il y avait un
langage officiel
tous les samedis soir par exemple les
garçons s'installait sur une grand-place
fort jolie d'ailleurs du xviiie siècle
portugais et et les filles tourner
autour mais là c'était le dragage pour
la bonne cause
c'était pour le mariage en fin de compte
m
[Musique]
voilà c'est chose que sa méthode je
m'étais dit en arrivant draguer vous
draguer et ça veut dire moi je sais pas
mais on arrivait de toute façon c'est
pas obligatoirement si j'ai envie de
connaître un garçon sur la plage aura
carrément hors jeu mais c'est pas pour
ça j'ai des arrière pensées qui n'ose
pas y avait et jeudi n'a aucune fille
l'avait lui même ne sait pas c'est pas
l'extase une fois qu'on a qu'on attend
il ya une fille
qu'est ce qu'on fait on laisse tomber
bon ça lui a d'autres choses à faire
mais c'est uniquement pour mater des
brèches et toi moi ce serait quoi
[Musique]